queen elizabeth is back to work
following the death of her beloved
husband prince philip
on tuesday for the first time since the
duke of edinburgh was laid to rest
the queen conducted a series of royal
engagements which also follows the
monarch's 95th birthday last week
well it is indeed a very somber birthday
for the queen of course the first
birthday that she will have spent
in 73 years without the duke of
edinburgh by her side
so a lonely birthday but she has not
been completely
on her own we understand that she has
been visited by some family members
today
i mean everything i'm hearing is that we
are going to see her back at work once
this period of morning is over
in these new images the monarch is seen
resuming her one-on-one meetings
a significant part of the queen's
standard day-to-day royal duties
while the queen remained at windsor
castle she had two virtual meetings with
incoming ambassadors from the republic
of latvia
and the republic of cote d'ivoire the
virtual event follows prince william and
kate middleton's in-person appearance
last week
they were given official permission to
resume royal engagements
just days after the duke of edinburgh
was laid to rest
the duke and duchess of cambridge met
with an air cadet squadron in london on
april 21st
the same day as the queen's milestone
birthday which
understandably looked much different
than her birthday celebrations in years
past
well i think we had expected a new
portrait of the queen that is what we
usually get
on an official birthday but i think
given that the royal family is still
in a period of mourning it was deemed
more appropriate to reissue an old
photograph that we've seen
and the other thing we didn't have today
was the 21 gun salute which usually
takes place
in london so i think both being quite
key indicators that
this birthday is being recognized it's
certainly not being celebrated
and it's very low key my father i
suppose the last
uh 70 years has given the most
remarkable
devoted service
to the queen it just goes to show he
he might have been our father
grandfather father-in-law but
but he meant so much to so many other
people before tuesday's engagement queen
elizabeth was only spending time with
close members of the royal family
which includes meetings she was believed
to have with grandson prince harry who
returned to america shortly after
philip's funeral now i think that there
were at least two meetings with the
queen
one in the gardens of windsor just
before the funeral
and a further private one-to-one meeting
between harry and the queen so this has
been an opportunity for something
of a family reconciliation harry's
incredibly fond
of his grandmother they share a very
close relationship it would have been
very important to him
that he got to have some time with his
grandmother before he went back to la